all aboard for a rebranding of britain's
railways
after 25 years of privatisation the
government wants to simplify a system
that's given passengers too many tickets
not enough trains and no one apparently
willing to take responsibility
when they're late the job of making
britain's historic network fit for the
future
will fall to a new body with a new name
albeit
one with a familiar ring quite simply
putting the passenger first getting
those trains to run on time
and having one national brand for our
railways which will be great british
railways
which will be collecting the fares
running the services
and making sure they work for the public
great british railways will take over
network rails responsibility for the
track and stations
as well as timetable planning and
ticketing
which will be run via a single branded
website and offer for the first time
flexible season tickets to better meet
passenger demand
it's quite expensive especially for a
student i remember the days when they
were nationalized and although they
didn't run
on time they were i think
you can improve the system you know they
say we put in billions now where you put
in the billions
we don't see it on the rails i think
passengers will see this as a good
step towards a more joined up more
efficient and a more coherent railway
joining up the train the track the money
and the planning in one place seems like
a good step
this is not nationalization
the trains will still be run by private
companies under new service agreements
after kovid 19 effectively brought the
franchise system
to an abrupt end passenger numbers are
down at around
30 percent of pre-pandemic levels and
the government's had to put in 12
billion pounds
just to get services like this one
running that's the most pressing
question for the railway isn't
how it's organized but when and if
commuters return the industry
gave the plans a cautious welcome
problem
with franchising is that it was very
restrictive it was one size
fits all and so we welcome the fact that
in this white paper
there is talk about not replacing it
with another one size fits all
but having different contracts in in
different areas of course we have to
look at the detail
but that we think will deliver a better
outcome for for passengers
not everyone will be on board the
government wants to change working
conditions
which may mean a fight with unions and
who will bear the cost of rebuilding
services
remains to be seen but ultimately
passengers will decide
if great british railways lives up to
its name
paul kelso sky news